foreign
[Music]
the only reason I agreed to a
traditional wedding was because you said
that we'd have moments alone
I love Carol
hi hello your future mother-in-law Cara
yep I know your name Carol I brought
some of the extras for the welcome bags
in case you want to make one for Sean oh
oh great thanks
all right thanks call me
not wearing any pants
I just want to ask and I hope it's okay
is that genetics
or is it like Pilates oh Mom now's not
the time the strands in your eyes they
color them one I've been looking forward
to this moment ever since baby Tommy was
cut out of my abdomen cheers everybody
[Music]
it's time now
there are pirates and they took
everybody lost it where is the pattern
of the pride
Robert Robert they're calling you thanks
a lot Carol
we're gonna head to the next Island for
help oh my count ten nine why are you
counting from ten but is this a rocket
launch you can find on four this weekend
hasn't exactly got a plan Pirates
chasing you wasn't on your vision board
you're the only thing on my mission
right is that blood
[Music]
you okay just you know I looked over
there and I saw the blood and you know I
think I saw some brain was that brain
stuff well you know what maybe we should
let's just step away
[Music]